hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Breanna white top five nudity in games
18 plus adults only from the mighty Rex
let's see if there's actual nudity in
these games because we don't get enough
nudity in games that's what I say it's a
problem in America
and the whole world America's problem
together I think we should put the wars
and stuff on hold yeah focus on nudity
and gaming yeah what's really
importantly what's gonna really educate
our children being better at sex and the
Japanese know how to do it they create
most of the games let's do this yes they
have
[Music]
I have a major heart over half I was
that guy whoever he is
Wow this like that's pretty Rocky this
is like real nudity yeah oh yeah oh yeah
what's he doing why is he just standing
he's got it [__] participate where
you do they come with me and experienced
issues
[Music]
oh no that's okay
hi Meryl of ronica did that did I go to
he our nation the ultimate of your kind
and our child will lead the rakia it's
the worst way to die dude you just come
in the best way are you uh could you die
happier than the guy it's your money
that's true point has been made
thank you you know a game Z it doesn't
matter to me right now
they're delivering on the nudity
[Applause]
[Music]
Goldin killer of innocent men women
children us Kira he abandoned his people
deliver the decadence of
returned
J to face judgment your judgement people
of Kurata
[Applause]
[Music]
terrified
[Applause]
look dear people
you do not
[Applause]
why didn't he go down
that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
when are you gonna finally bring this
piece of junk my heart couldn't take it
oh wow here vanished oh oh yeah oh yeah
do you have any idea how much they cost
they're gonna have sex on the horse
oh it's okay then the last [__] hunter
[Music]
we're like the last witch hunter oh no
oh wow
wow dude come on you're on the unicorn
that's a little inappropriate I want to
see his penis that's a good name a fair
way oh it's the unicorn dead Oh may just
be a statue
we only get back to the week it's
actually a little weird that those are
great nipples
those are like great nipples looks lost
then dick you know rescue to squeeze
okay Wow
all right I don't know what the games
were in that yeah I wish they wouldn't
name the game I saw the last witch
hunter that was about it yeah Deadpool
it looks like the first one is almost
like God of War or something like that
but like I said it's very Game of
Thrones like you're in a whorehouse the
brothel looking for a quest piece but
you also get to enjoy exact action if I
was in the first game like I would have
liked mission don't care anymore don't
care let's just participate that should
have been an RPG option for you to be
able to choose whether or not you go can
the mission boning a bunch of chicks one
thing I notice is something like boobs
and like a little bit of ass but I think
we're at a time in a Danish where we can
see a vagina or a penis I'm just a
little bit worried that if they can't
animate them very well then it's just
gonna be funny as opposed to like
sensual true because yeah the boobage in
this so a lot of them looked really good
they look great yeah especially in the
last wish under like those nips were
fantastic like I was like very realistic
and great-looking boobs
it was good stuff well done yeah what
was that weird slicing that girl's
throat though yeah and then he slices
these slices that girl started the nice
start was completely unrelated it was
like a great way to just make me go
uh-huh
and then that happened I know oh wow my
emotions are going threw me for a loop I
wasn't sure how to feel then he's having
sex with that one chicken he's like so
into it but she doesn't really seem like
she's into it she's just like having a
monologue just totally in another world
yeah weird tribal world and that's
praying mantis [__] yeah like make love
rip head off goodbye dude I couldn't
like it if Veronica would like hold a
knife up against me yeah yeah like while
she's on top the adrenalin danger yeah
and then if she actually like cut my
throat right thought you'd be super into
that Oh biggest orgasm ever sure yeah
quickly followed by dead mm-hmm I lose a
lot of blood probably down there too
no reason why but then she'd have to
clean it up you know and yeah but we
have the Handy comm app but they suck
they are good never gonna order through
them again pros and cons pros and cons
you know you got away that option yeah
how do you feel about nudity in video
games honestly honestly I definitely
think there's a place for it yeah
there's cows it's in TV shows yeah
movies it's in comics you know it's
everywhere so why not games you know
it's just like any other form of media I
guess because games are known to be more
heavily accessed by teenagers you know
then you just think that's a connotation
that's no longer true okay well well
debate and I think I just don't see my
argument that I play house of romance
option and you get to pursue a romance
and there's a love scene it's not real
nudity though in most of them like when
Mario does peach from behind super smash
brothers for smashes that yeah anyway
guys thanks for sharing that video along
with the rest of the world if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe today
and become a read a kitty come a
rejecter or reject the bots today
whatever you want to call it brianna why
does a gaming channel please a little
bit of games on there no nudity no new
today she has let down many of people
superfans you should check out ciliary
it's pretty much the same benefit
Donald Harrison racism is out of control
I'm a brother so Govan me a shout out
could bring peace to the world also love
your channel I've been a fan of yours
since the dawn of Justice trailer
release love your comedy and the pornhub
mentions hello well I'm a huge fan of
that to hardly watch on the laptop I'm
more of a mobile app fan they don't have
a mobile app dude I've tried the one hub
mobile app doesn't work okay there's no
there's no porn app okay you type in
porn a purely gonna get [__] the [__]
damn this is getting weird and personal
tell me about what Eve's shouted out
homie well he's a brother mean he's
black and he's seen racism's out of
control and I'm here to represent my
black brother Donald Harrison let's
check him out there's one thing I know
about black people oh yeah this guy
definitely has a huge [__] you can tell
by this picture that he is hung like a
horse you look like you've smoked a lot
of weed too this is the various stoner I
get a STONER vibe from this guy I get
like a STONER with a big dick kind of
odd
yeah stoner with a big dick I guess that
that's kind of cool we need more black
people because we need bigger penises in
the world oh so you're saying like you
know social Darwinism your evolution of
larger penises that's what you want
yes that's my thesis hypothesis yes so
you close your eyes and you look 10
years into your future yeah I just
primarily see why people they're wearing
pants but their thing is hanging out of
their zipper yeah then all the people
with medium-sized to small penises going
to hiding and they get shot you know
kind of like The Hunger Games with the
peacekeepers who just like going and
sort of Nile eating you know groups of
people in the districts
the people with regular to small penises
are good tape measures yeah you're good
laser scan it and then they handcuff
them and then they just annihilate them
in front of a crowd gotta get rid of the
weaklings I'm gonna be part of the weak
links unfortunately yeah I shouldn't
have touched this plan before I realized
the size of my average penis
no you gotta envision a different future
for yourself or you could be part of the
resistance you know you could be Katniss
ever penis no